today's episode is sponsored by blinkist
the app that lets you
read or listen to an entire nonfiction
book
in just 15 minutes you can try blinkist
totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
david pakman i put the link right below
this video
we're still finding out details about
this just unconscionable tragedy that
took place in beirut lebanon a couple of
days ago but we do now know enough that
we can at least say
a few things on tuesday there was
an absolutely gigantic explosion
in beirut lebanon at warehouses that
stored
highly explosive materials and the video
of this explosion
looks the way that nuclear weapons are
often portrayed in hollywood films
and it was in fact one of the largest
explosions
uh essentially in the history of
humanity
shock waves smashed homes and ripped off
building facades and
so far uh the death toll is at 157 now
just yesterday was at 1 13
so it's climbing rapidly there's another
80 people currently unaccounted for
ominously and more than 5 000 people
have been injured but that those those
numbers are probably a fraction of what
ultimately is going to be uncovered
tragically the shock wave spread
so far that 300 000 people were left
without homes because even miles away
the impacts of this explosion were felt
now
very early in the process of trying to
figure out what happened
on tuesday donald trump wildly talked
about
this as an attack he said it looked like
a bomb and to be very clear
the reason i didn't report about this
yesterday is
i knew trump had made those assertions
with no evidence and
i didn't want to fall into similar type
of speculation
and and in fact now two days after the
event
uh it appears that what donald trump
floated was completely wrong now i'll
talk a little bit more later about him
doubling down on that but to focus on
what we do know
this appears to have been close to 3 000
tons of ammonium nitrate which can be
used in fertilizers
and in bombs which was stored for years
at the port
in beirut lebanon after being seized now
it was stored
incorrectly it appears without the
proper safety measures and so far
it looks like inaction and negligence
are to blame
for the explosion the words terrorism
attack bomb are not being used and from
what we know so far it was very
irresponsible for donald trump to use
those words
there are reports that what triggered
the explosion
was maybe related to construction or
repair work being done
at a warehouse it's still early and even
that has not yet been confirmed and
it is believed that these explosive
materials had actually been sitting
there for somewhere
uh in the range of six to seven years so
right at the blast site it's complete
devastation and death
in a sort of one mile radius area there
are partial
and full building collapses and many
many injuries
in a two plus mile radius from the blast
you start to go in the direction of
windows blown out damage to buildings
more on the injury side again
and there are damaged buildings all the
way out to six
miles from the blast if you can imagine
so this is now a full-blown disaster
zone it's a disaster zone it's a
catastrophe humanitarian groups are
trying to get into the area to provide
help other non-profits and of course
everything is in the context of
coronavirus and that is
significantly compounding the difficulty
when you have a raging pandemic any kind
of humanitarian mission becomes more
more difficult and again the the blast
is considered to be about 20 percent of
the size
of hiroshima i mean just think about the
magnitude of that
now again there is almost
no important global news story
in 2020 in which our president
does not become a reckless participant
in case in point
calling this an attack early floating
the idea of a bomb
was completely irresponsible at first it
seemed maybe he was leaking information
from a classified briefing he
had received maybe he knew something
that had not yet been made public
he didn't he was just wildly speculating
again showing that
uh there's a level of irresponsibility
that he just can't get away from as
president of the united states and i'm
going to talk more later about trump
doubling down on it but instantly you
have right wingers
posting everywhere on the internet it is
an attack because of what donald trump
said the the reality is that
we probably still don't know the whole
story but
that type of speculation from a
president is childishly irresponsible
and in fact
there's a long list of ammonium nitrate
explosions including here in the united
states that you might even remember
in 2013 there was an ammonium nitrate
explosion in west
texas which also led to speculation
about terrorism and attacks and bombs
that's not what it was 15 people did die
there so there can always be foul play
this is not an out of the world
unbelievable situation as it's been
reported and trump's ignorance and
irrational speculation as always
causing more problems once again okay
this is this is a sort of a complicated
thing to discuss
but at some point we meaning the united
states collectively
we are going to owe the world an
explanation
and an apology and i don't mean just
generally for donald trump but i'm
talking more broadly because of our
failure on coronavirus
i'm talking broadly because of our
failure to continue leading on climate
change i'm talking about our failure
really to just hold back the advancement
of humanity
instead regressing dramatically over the
last three and a half years and maybe
for another four
now to set the stage accurately
i'm not pretending that the united
states nor the world were
idyllic panaceas during the era of
barack obama that would be
revisionist history that would be wrong
that's certainly not the point of this
segment to pretend things were just
perfect
until donald trump became president but
as an example
we were at least an important part of
thinking about how to deal with climate
change when barack obama was president
of the united states
we hadn't figured it out certainly but
we were serious participants in the
conversation
the obama administration understood the
u.s
is disproportionately relative to our
population a big polluter
a big emitter of of of pollution and
emissions
and we were taking it seriously not
enough was done
we had not figured it out but our role
was at least
respectable around the world our role
now on climate change
has gone from respectable to not
respectable
to having no role whatsoever because
we're actually a huge part of the
problem as donald trump has
claimed that climate change is a hoax
created by china propped up oil and gas
while loosening car emission standards
and the world has rightly
started either ignoring us in these
important climate change conversations
or actually pointing out that we're a
huge part of the problem
on coronavirus of course this
administration has proven that it still
matters who is president we have seen
arguably one of the worst responses in
the world
to the pandemic i don't know how much
time i have to spend on that today since
we've covered it almost daily for months
but suffice it to say almost any
functioning adult
would have said i don't need to lead
this let's defer to the doctors
and we'd be better off right we didn't
need
anything outlandish to better handle
coronavirus than the way this
administration has handled it we just
needed some adult to say
oh i'm not an expert in this but i know
who is
let's let le let's allow them to lead
the way
we've talked about voting trump out as
only being
the first step and that's true from a
policy
standpoint but it's also true from the
standpoint of defeating trumpism
defeating trump will not instantly end
trumpism if donald trump loses in
november and leaves the oval office in
january
but there's another area in which
defeating donald trump is only the first
step which is
starting to rebuild our alliances around
the world
starting to recover some semblance of
respect from our historical allies and
from the people of this planet
so this is not about being ashamed of
the country
even though certainly you wouldn't be
wrong to feel that right now as we have
become a laughingstock
this is not about punishing trump
supporters
although there's no doubt that they are
responsible for the fact that this
president was elected
this is about realizing that part of
being respected again
and rebuilding those relationships is
going to be
an implicit apology some kind of
explanation
as to our commitment to fixing the
disaster that the united states has been
globally during the time of donald trump
now if donald trump were to win in
november the case for such an apology
and an explanation and a rehabilitation
of our reputation becomes much more
difficult
almost 63 million people voted for
donald trump in 2016.
the reality is some number close to that
or even more are going to vote for him
again
in 2020. the question of course is going
to be
do enough additional people vote for joe
biden
such that donald trump loses in the
electoral college now in the next
segment i'm going to talk about the
reality that
any of you that thinks biden's got this
is not based in fact and i'm going to go
into detail about that after the break
but let's imagine even if donald trump
is defeated in november
there will still be the inconvenient and
humiliating reality
that somewhere between probably 60 and
65 million americans in all likelihood
will have seen the last four years of
trump
and the disaster that it's been and they
will say i'm voting
for another four and they will vote for
donald trump a second time
so how do we get out of this removing
donald trump is only going to be step
0.1 in the process the world deserves
answers
the world deserves an explanation we owe
it to the world and
an explanation about how we will not
allow the country to be hijacked
by the non-thinking ideas of the 60 plus
million people who even if trump loses
in november
will have voted for another four years
so what is the path forward i actually
don't have the answers
i want to hear from you i'm on twitter
at d pacman
we'll take a break and we'll follow up
about this either tomorrow or next week
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly
what one of my favorite apps lets you do
it's called blinkist and what they do is
take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
nonfiction book
in just 15 minutes i recently read a
brief history of time of course by the
great stephen hawking this is a book
that i have been aware of for so long
and
other things got in the way and it was
fantastic to check it out on blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about
eight bucks a month and you get the
entire library
but you can try it totally free and get
25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
slash david pakman i've put the link
right underneath this video
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
today's new members of the day are paul
smith and stefan
byrne paul and stefan thank you for your
support
and also a big thank you to kristen
diesel who is today's longtime
sustaining member of the day kristin's
been a member for almost five years
and i invite you to sign up for
membership at joinpacman.com you'll get
the daily
bonus show world famous as well as
commercial free audio and video streams
of the entire show the members only
newsletter
and so much more grab a membership at
jointpakman.com
okay some interesting uh so i actually
am glad to see on the david pakman show
subreddit this morning which is of
course
uh davidpakman.com
a post asking is trump making a
comeback linking to a bunch of different
polling data
which seems to suggest that the huge
lead that
biden maybe had about a month ago
may be narrowing now i i'm going to make
the case
in the next segment that there is no
such lead it's not a question of it's
narrowing it's it does not exist
and i will make the mathematical case i
will make a qualitative case for you as
well
and i'm really glad that people on the
subreddit are discussing that now also
i don't want to spend a lot of time on
this but
there have been allegations made
that i eat mac and cheese with a spoon
which is really weird like if you need a
spoon for mac and cheese it's really
like a pasta soup i use
spoons only for desserts and soups not
for
pasta um and i i guess that
in some circles this is considered
controversial but yes i do eat
uh mac and cheese with a fork i think
that that's the correct utensil this is
not really important given everything
that we have going on
but somehow this triggered a lot of
people in my audience and i really don't
know why so if that's something you want
to weigh in on
the place to do it would be the david
pakman show subreddit davidpakman.com
r-e-d-d-i-t but the focus here really
important to get back to the material
important
materially important things i don't know
when people talk about is trump making a
comeback i don't know that donald trump
needs to make a comeback and that's what
i want to
really focus in on next there are people
in my audience and elsewhere
who are getting too confident about the
upcoming presidential election i'm
scared by it
you guys are scaring me and so what i
want to do today
is to make the case that not only could
donald trump win reelection
nothing major really needs to change for
him to win re-election he could be
winning right now
from an electoral college standpoint so
if you don't look at the details
and you say oh biden's plus 10 bidens
plus
twelve there was a poll where biden was
plus fifteen seems like biden's winning
easily
and he's also winning key battleground
states biden is going to run away with a
historic electoral college victory
no no if by the end of this clip
i have not convinced you that we should
be very careful of interpreting the data
we have in that way
then i will have failed to do my job i
deserve to be cancelled
hello if by the end of this segment i've
not convinced you that we need to be
very very
careful about what's going on so let's
start with national polling
whenever there's a poll that says joe
biden is up 12.
joe biden is up 10. joe biden is up 15
it gets a ton of attention and certainly
if joe biden wins the popular vote by 10
12 or 15
trump's done that's not actually
what the mathematical case today is
let's look at the numbers
today and understand the numbers first
of all
the polls that had biden up 10 12 and 15
we're not getting any more of those
polls okay the last poll where biden was
up double digits was july 23rd he was up
10.
more recently biden is only up 3 in a
number of polls
and on average biden is up by 6.4
6.4 is very different than 15 my friends
so 6.4 still sounds pretty good
but understand that if you look at any
individual poll you have to understand
the margin of error
hugely important so for example the
latest
yougov poll has a 3.3 percent
margin of error so when the yougov poll
says that biden is winning by 9 49 to 40
trump's 40 could actually be 43.3 and
it would still be within the margin of
error of the poll
biden's 49 could really be 45.7
so a poll which promotes as a headline
biden plus 9 could really be
biden plus 2.4 and the poll
would still be correct this is what we
this is why we have a confidence
interval
and a margin of error if biden is really
only winning by 2.4
trump could win the electoral college
remember we have
polling for the national popular vote
but we have an electoral college system
in 2016 hillary won the popular vote by
i think it was 2.1 or 2.2
but lost the electoral college so for
people who are saying
what could happen to allow trump to
catch up to biden
nothing has to happen within the margin
of error
today donald trump has the support where
he
could win the electoral college if we
have similar
battleground results to those in 2016.
you don't need an october surprise
when the current lead for trump might
only be i'm sorry the current lead for
biden might only be 2.4 trump won 2016
with a 2.1 percent deficit in the
popular vote so that's
national popular vote polling let's now
go to step two
you might say biden's winning hugely
in key battleground states well remember
in 2016
the national popular vote polls were
accurate
but there were state polls that didn't
get it right
state polls had some problems in 2016.
so
hillary was winning the polling in
wisconsin going into the election
trump won wisconsin that's just one
example
so once you concede the national polling
that looks like a big lead for biden
could actually be like a two-point lead
for biden
state polling was off in some states in
2016.
you have to come to the conclusion that
biden might not really be winning
electorally right now
and then lastly i talked about this
yesterday when you look at
voter registration it doesn't look
that great it is true that in many
states if you look only at
new registrations meaning people who
have never been registered before
who maybe were not even 18 years old in
2016. when you look just at
new registrations democrats have an
advantage over republicans
they've registered more new voters but
as i told you yesterday
in florida pennsylvania arizona iowa
north carolina
in terms of the number of registered
democrats versus republicans
today versus 2016 the advantage
has been in favor of republicans and
against democrats
and the reasons for this are people who
have moved from one state to another
people who have switched party
registrations deaths
this is separate from who is going to
choose to vote
but this is not the type of data you
want to see if you want to be confident
that joe biden is going to run away with
this thing so when you step back
and you say well the polls if you
account for margin of error
look very similar to 2016 there were
state polls
in 2016 that were wrong and then you
realize
you know over the next three months if
the economy improves a little bit
if coronavirus gets better
if we get a vaccine or a good treatment
that trump will
try to take credit for a one or one and
a half point swing
from where we are today in trump's
direction and trump wins the electoral
college
so i hope that i have convinced you
that we need to be far more skeptical
about these biden's running away with it
ideas that we are starting to see
you must run as if we are behind
this is going to be a huge fight it
actually
doesn't look nearly as good as some are
claiming and i'm
very worried some of you are worrying me
that we are getting complacent that some
people think the data
clearly points to biden running away
with this review this video
if you need to fact check me go
item by item and if you do
you can come to only one conclusion
which is that there is not
actually evidence to say right now that
joe biden is going to easily win in
november
he might win hugely and he might lose
and we're going to we're going to have
to fight this we're going to have more
coverage of this
on the show's instagram page david
pakman shows our instagram
handle while you are there you can also
follow me on instagram at david.pacman
you should see
what's going on in my backyard which you
can find out on my instagram
david.pacman we'll take a quick break
and be back right after this
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on your
support and the easiest way is through
membership which includes the world
famous bonus show as well as commercial
free audio and video streams of the show
just for members sign up today at
joinpackman.com
coupon code saves you 40 vote soon 18.
[Music]
welcome back to the david pakman show
it's great to welcome back to the
program today congressman ro khanna
representing california's 17th district
located in the heart of silicon valley
um where to start right i mean i think
maybe the the
first place would be second stimulus
given what's going on with coronavirus
discussions of
a payroll tax discussions of an
extension
or uh expansion and to what degree
of this enhanced unemployment what are
your priorities what do you think needs
to happen and when
well first we have to be clear-eyed
about what the problem is the problem is
that they're not enough jobs i mean
people
don't have enough money to pay basic
rent to get groceries
so when people say oh these unemployment
checks are some disincentive to work
they're five
times the job seekers as there are jobs
and the irony is that by not giving this
money it's not just that we're doing
enormous damage to middle class and
working class families i mean
some are having foreclosures some aren't
being able to get enough
nutritious food for their kids it's also
that we're damaging the economy because
the economy is stalling
if people don't have money to spend so
uh the priority has to be to
stick to the six hundred dollars to get
that extended through the end of the
year
to get funding for states and localities
of course as you know david i've been
pushing for two thousand dollars a month
for
for people uh that wasn't in the house
bill so i don't wanna
mislead people and it's unrealistic
that's gonna be in the cards for this
but
but we have to stick to uh the six
hundred dollars the stimulus and
the fun money for uh state and local
governments
i was initially at least sort of loosely
open to the idea of the payroll tax cut
that has been floated by donald trump
i then changed my mind because i i
realized that it seems like a way
to weaken social security and medicare
and to then maybe use that deliberate
weakening as a reason to justify further
weakening or defunding so i ended up
deciding i didn't like it and in
particular because
the way i read it it's only a holiday it
is not actually a
cut in other words you would then on
your taxes when you file
potentially owe it back and so i ended
up saying i
i don't like it where are you on it yeah
i don't think it makes sense
particularly because we have the
challenge now a business is not opening
i mean if you
if you work for a restaurant or indoor
dining it doesn't matter if you have a
payroll tax cut that's not going to
get you back to work until the virus is
under control and i
don't see it getting under control until
the next year until we have a vaccine
and better therapeutics so
uh you could argue in a in a traditional
recession
uh a payroll tax cut may provide some
added incentive to
to hiring uh it favors businesses over
workers but you may say okay
we need it as one tool but in a pandemic
where
uh the ability to create new jobs is
restricted by public health i
i don't think it makes sense so i'm
curious whether you have any other
as as a member of of the house uh
insight
into what we might call the real case
numbers and what i mean by that is a
couple of examples are
we saw this leveling off after july 16th
which was exactly when data started
going to hhs instead of the cdc
it's a question mark although i'm not
alleging deliberate foul play yet
but then on top of that florida's
numbers have gone down but they stopped
testing on thursday because of the
hurricane and only restarted yesterday
so that would be a very clear reason why
we don't have a complete picture there
the california coveted 19 dashboard
yesterday put up a message saying that
for several days cases had been under
reported
although the reason why is not yet clear
to me are you working with the same data
the public is working with do you have
any other insights into into more
accurate data
we're working with the same data we
don't get any briefing of
better data and i think whether uh it's
deliberate uh
i don't know but it's certainly not
transparent i mean there's been a lot of
obfuscation there isn't a clear way of
collecting this data and the reality is
it's the hospitalizations and the debts
that
continue to be uh outrageous i mean
especially when you look at other
countries so the cases of course matter
but
the no one is can dispute the
data that we still don't have this under
control again the amount of debts that
we're unfortunately facing and given the
amount of hospitalization we're facing
the topic of cases cases versus tests
if you don't test you don't find cases
case fatality rate
versus deaths per capita this all kind
of exploded on monday night in this
interview that the president gave to
axios jonathan swann
i'm i'm guessing you saw the interview i
did i mean and and you know it's very
hard
well the president has one skill he's
very good at marketing and branding but
you can't spin death you can't market
when people are in hospitals are filled
and so he was trying to
say when the relevant statistic is the
percentage of people with cases
uh who are dying in and it is true that
that percentage has gone down as
treatments have
uh improved uh but uh that that is not
the relevant statistic the relevant
statistic
is not uh what percentage of people who
are getting
covet or dying the relevant statistic is
why are so many americans
getting covered compared to other
countries and uh
i i think the president was unable to
spin his way out of that he obviously
understands the distinction he's just
hoping that he can
fool people but you can't fool people
when it's their own public health
that's interesting so you think he does
understand these
these issues in more detail than maybe
he lets on
and he's spinning because i actually
question whether he understands some of
this stuff
your sense is that it's deliberate and
that it's optics
i think in that case he's i mean i don't
think he's he's deeply reflective but i
think he looks for the numbers that
make the most sense and he tries to uh
to put them out if the if the death
rates were lower he would have put that
number out so i
i think his modus up run his whole life
has been uh
take any news uh exaggerated a bit
uh make it sound great and to your
advantage and in many cases
that has worked with him with people who
are busy in their lives and don't have
the time to look through
long articles the challenge here is
suddenly people are taking the time to
pay attention
uh because it's their own health it's
their parents health it's their
neighbor's health
and so they have far more details and
when you have a situation of an engaged
citizenry on an issue
trump's strategy really falls flat and
that's why i think
you've seen uh him struggling what do
you think
or i guess let me rephrase it in a
different way i imagine
that if you were scheduled to do an
interview
that your staff felt very strongly would
potentially be a disaster
that you logic would reach you and you
might
listen to advice that says this maybe
isn't a good interview to do
the context is how do you think these
insane interviews are even happening
with the president
is it that he doesn't listen to his
staff and that he believes he'll always
come out on top i mean i'm trying to
understand how these things are
happening so frequently
yeah i think from his perspective he's
succeeded to quote unquote succeed in a
material sense and a lot of things he's
done in life he's managed to
talk himself out of bankruptcies he came
out of nowhere and became president of
the united states and i think he has a
lot of
self-confidence in hubris that uh
his view is the more exposure the better
and that he can talk his way
uh out of anything uh and this is a a
common problem when people
become president obviously it's
massively exaggerated in
trump's case where he uh does not have
the
humility to to see his own weaknesses
and i think that's creating a large
amount of the problems for him
so what what does that get you thinking
about in terms of
potential biden versus trump debates
i've said from a practical standpoint
i can't think of an election i voted in
where i care less about seeing debates i
mean it's just
i just think i have more than enough
information uniquely so in this case to
make a decision and that's that's to
vote for joe biden
there's speculation about joe biden
the debates are better for biden or the
the debates are better for trump and a
lot of that depends on
you know what your belief is about the
cognitive state of of either or both of
them what's your sense about the debates
not
generally but in this particular case
well i think that
biden uh will debate and should debate
because i think the story of him
uh not debating would be a much bigger
deal and lead to speculation that is
unfair and wrong and i think people
underestimate by then i mean if you look
uh i
as you know i co-chaired the bernie
sanders campaign we were very excited
when we had a one-on-one opportunity
with biden
and i think everyone would tell you that
biden held his own i mean
it was not a knockout punch for uh
bernie sanders if anything i think it
was probably a draw so
my sense is biden's debate skills
improved a lot uh through the course of
the primary
uh and i think one of the mistakes
donald trump is making is by so
uh putting all his chips in these
debates
and setting the bar so low uh if
biden has a satisfactory performance
uh he's gonna really i think get the
upper hand and i i i think biden's k
perfectly capable of having a solid
performance that's super interesting
because i remember that in the sort of
uh
twitter bernie space before the
one-on-one debates
there were very high hopes that joe
biden was going to implode and this was
going that was going to be the moment at
which bernie took over and as you
mentioned
it really was a draw in a sense i do
think that the heavy focus on
coronavirus probably helped joe biden to
some degree and there was less focus in
that debate on other issues
but so even within the bernie camp there
were high hopes about that one-on-one
debate
yeah no i mean that was sort of our
final uh hope to try to shake up the
race obviously we were doing very well
headed into super tuesday we had a
different
disappointing super tuesday uh it was uh
not anticipated that everyone would
withdraw and endorse biden
it's a free country people can do that
but really no one thought the
establishment would coalesce around buy
them that quickly
and so we needed a game changer and we
thought this debate was
a place uh we could have one i mean
bernie objectively i think had done much
better in
a lot of the debates leading up to that
debate than biden had
but buying uh is exceeded expectations
in
in that debate and so uh he's certainly
capable
of of doing that and uh
i so i i think trump is making a mistake
if he's putting
all his eggs in in that basket
so let's talk a little bit about the
last three months here to the election
where
uh every member of the house is up for
re-election
33 plus two senate seats are available
and of course it's the presidential
election there are some
in my audience that are feeling very
confident about the presidential piece
seeing polls that have joe biden doing
very well
today i went through and pointed out for
example
in a recent poll where joe biden is
winning by nine when you look at the
margin of error
that could be actually only a 2.4
percent lead for joe biden and hillary
won by 2.2 in 2016
at the popular vote level but lost the
electoral college
when i look at state by state polling
which looks quite good for joe biden
the state polling was not great in 2016.
national was good in other words hillary
was up three and one by two point two
that's that's great
wisconsin said hillary was going to win
and she lost so
i am very cautious about any complacency
at all going into this election while
some are extraordinarily confident
what do you think is the right
perspective on the data
i think caution is is better i would say
if the election were tomorrow
uh biden would win because i think the
the polling is so overwhelming in one
direction but the election is not
tomorrow and
there's a lot that can happen in the
next 90 days the debates being one of
them that doesn't mean
don't debate uh because that would be an
issue in and of itself but the point is
that the conventions haven't happened
the debates haven't happened
we don't know what the economy is going
to look like uh
come end of september and october we
don't know whether coronavirus is going
to be on the retreat in some sense and
getting slightly better or
whether it's getting uh worse we don't
know the impact of who he picks as a
vice president
so this is not a situation of george w
bush in 2008 where george w bush had
collapsed into the 30s
and really the american people had uh
totally written him off and i don't
think it's even
at the level of jimmy carter who've been
i really admire timmy carter i think he
was
an exceptional person but uh trump has
been stubbornly at 40 41 42 that means
if he gets a five point swing and gets
his approval up to 45
uh this is a very competitive race and
then you put it it
you put on top of that uh this fact that
uh the voter suppression the the the
difficulty of mail-in ballots
uh the energetic nature of his base uh
and i think we have to
assume that this is going to be a drag
out fight
when it comes to the senate it looks to
me as though
if democrats keep the house which you
are projected to
if joe biden were to win that a lot of
what
gets done in the next two years depends
on whether democrats can take control of
the senate and
i've looked at the races up and down and
certainly there's a path now that is a
clearer path than than it was 6 and 12
and 18 months ago
what races are you looking at in the
senate and what's your sense of where
that might go
well i think arizona we've got a great
job with mark kelly i think in north
carolina with cunningham we have a very
very strong shot
uh i think susan collins is in deep
trouble i think steve bullock
and montana has made that race much more
competitive
uh our candidates are doing very well
but i think it largely depends on
on biden i mean if biden has a kind of
win that his polling currently shows i
think we have a very good chance of
carrying the senate if this race
tightens uh as i fear it may
uh then you know our chances of getting
it
the sweep we need in senate seats uh
becomes harder and it became harder
where
some of the the candidates won the right
candidates from the republican side in
the
kansas primary and and you know they
have they've been fortunate not to elect
some of the most crazy people where we
could have had a pickup
opportunity last thing i want to touch
on
there's been this idea now of could an
election be delayed
what would it look like what would be
the reasons
are there ways for the president to stay
in the oval office and i've tried not to
give this more attention than it
deserves because when when it comes
right down to it we've not had a federal
election delay in the history of this
country
on january 20th trump stops being
president if he's not re-elected and
then you know a series of other things
happen
is this at all being taken seriously
among you and your colleagues is there
is there a discussion of this or is it
basically just not not being paid
attention to
my concern is not that he's going to
delay the election my concern is
that there is a early reporting of
election day results uh where which tend
to favor republicans traditionally
and he may be and have an early lead in
one of these battleground states
and then there's delay and not proper
counting of absentee ballots and if you
have a few percent election in a place
like florida in a place like wisconsin
that there's tremendous pressure put on
the state legislatures
to certify uh those states in in favor
of trump so
uh i i don't see a situation where the
state certified joe biden the house and
senate certified joe biden and
donald trump stays in the white house i
think a far more risky situation is like
1876 where you
actually have state legislators uh
working conspiring with the white house
uh to
uh give the result to trump on
on a close call and that that to me is
the the disenfranchisement and
and states uh calling it for trump are
what
what i think are the deep concerns yeah
i'm not conspiratorial by nature but
after months of railing against vote by
mail when donald trump tweeted two days
ago or three days ago
everybody in florida should vote by mail
m my mind immediately goes to
what does he know about ron desantis
plans that now all of a sudden make him
very
into the idea of florida voting by mail
and i think it goes along the lines
you're talking about which is the role
that the state and secretaries of states
may have yeah and i mean look he's
doesn't even try to get principal
uh a any uh any due i mean he's
basically saying okay
in the states that i need absentee
voting please vote absentee in the
states where absentee voting may hurt me
don't do it
uh it's just raw uh power but this is
they understand that if it were an
election where which was clean
where everyone who should be wanting to
should be voting and wanting to vote
votes
uh trump can't overcome those numbers so
uh
the the disenfranchisement the try
trying to create confusion
uh and then the biggest risk i think is
this idea that donald trump imagined up
on election day he's up by a couple
points in
wisconsin or florida even if a week
later we know he's going to lose by four
or five points
you could see him declaring victory and
it becomes
much harder than for the states where
those state legislators are in trump
heavy districts to do the right thing
and so that that i think is the bigger
uh bigger fear of how they would cheat
or take that take the election
i uh completely agree and it's exactly
the point
that i've been making congressman ro
khanna representing california 17th
district
always a pleasure and i really
appreciate your time appreciate it david
i appreciate all of your commentary and
look forward to
being back on the david pakman show
at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on the
support of our viewers and listeners and
one way to keep us going
is through patreon where you can pledge
as little as one dollar per month
or as much as you want at patreon.com
slash david pakman show great perks and
benefits as well read about them
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
so donald trump held another one of
these press briefings yesterday and
uh the the press briefings are
increasingly sort of an outlet for
donald trump's panic over failed
interview after failed interview on
monday night the axios interview that
trump gave to jonathan swann
was such a train wreck that trump
decided yesterday morning
i'm going to call in to fox and friends
that'll be a nice softball interview
well
we reviewed the fox and friends
interview and again donald trump was a
complete and total disaster
he seems unable to help himself so
yesterday in the afternoon evening
running half an hour late put him sort
of in the evening category here on the
east coast
trump had another one of these white
house press briefings and it was just
unfounded conspiracy after conspiracy
donald trump
losing all connection with reality and i
want to take a look at some of the key
moments now you might remember that on
tuesday
trump had floated the idea that the
explosion in beirut lebanon was an
attack
and he also mentioned that it looked
like a bomb now at the time there was no
evidence of that whatsoever
it was completely irresponsible for
donald trump to float that idea
and since as we learn more about what
went on
there continues to be a complete lack of
evidence that that is what happened
donald trump was asked about it
yesterday and multiple times
doubled down floating even more
conspiratorial ideas
about explosive devices all with zero
evidence also one other thing here that
i want you to pay special attention to
you're going to notice that trump starts
referring to lebanon
as that country he never says the word
lebanon during this entire press
briefing
it looks to me that donald trump doesn't
know that beirut
is in lebanon and so he avoids having to
make that clear by referring to lebanon
as that country pay special attention to
that
the primary focus of this clip is
trump's baseless conspiracies
so there's been some question about your
comments yesterday
saying that it was an attack and that
you heard from military officials
that there was uh you know an explosion
that looked like some sort of
water i can tell you whatever happened
it's terrible but they don't really know
what it is nobody knows yet
at this moment they're looking it could
i mean how can you say accident somebody
was
you know left some terrible
explosive type devices and things around
perhaps
perhaps it was that perhaps it was an
attack i don't think anybody can say
right now we're looking into it very
strongly right now it's
uh i mean you have some people think it
was an attack and you have
some people that think it wasn't in any
event it was a terrible event and a lot
of people were killed and a tremendous
number of people were badly
wounded injured and we're standing with
with that country you know we have a
very good relationship with that country
but it's a country under
a lot of turmoil a lot of problems but
we stand with them
none of what donald trump said there is
based in
any fact he says maybe someone left
explosive devices
there's no evidence of that he's just
making that up
some people think it was an attack there
could have been
explosive devices there's no connection
to reality whatsoever now you expect
this stuff
from you know the enclaves of the
internet that we've all come to
sadly be familiar with over the last
three and a half years
but this is the president of the united
states just randomly and
wildly floating conspiracies that occur
to him
then another one hear donald trump uh
posits
without any evidence that there was some
kind of conspiracy
in new york congressional primaries
all to make him look bad this is just
wild and unhinged new york they had the
carolyn
maloney situation and i criticized it
badly over the last two years
and two days i mean i gave it some very
very strong criticism
and all of a sudden like a miracle they
just approved the winner well what
happened did the
person that was second concede the race
even though it was
very close and all mixed up they have a
terrible situation in new york with the
ballots you know that
and as soon as i said well i think you
should have a new election because the
election obviously they're not going to
know what to do i think you should have
a new election
they all of a sudden announced a winner
i assume it was her but they announced
the winner
well i don't agree with it did somebody
speak to the person on the other side
the opponent did they
do something for the opponent on the
other side take a look at paterson new
jersey take a look at many things it's
all over
newspapers what's going on with the
mail-in
ballots they send out millions of
ballots
millions of ballots they're totally
unprepared to do it and then they come
back in the millions
uh it's going to be a disaster
completely baseless
allegations and remember donald trump
keeps talking about vote by mail
fraud as a reason not to vote by mail in
november
and he points to this new york race
this situation in new york is related to
postmarks and mishandling by the city
there has been no voter fraud alleged
in this race at all never mind confirmed
none of that race has anything to do
with fraud
and yet donald trump is fully in with
these baseless
conspiracies now then at the end of the
press briefing
again the topic of beirut was brought up
and trump sort of stumbles through the
answer
and abruptly ends the press briefing
again failing to ever say the word
lebanon
it seems to me trump doesn't know that
beirut is in lebanon
uh and again saying it could have been a
bomb that was set off despite there
being
no evidence posited so far
said today that based on what
he had heard the incident in beirut
he felt was an accident now he's
disagreed with you on other things
before do you have any comment about his
remarks
whatever he uh if he if that's what he
heard i think that i've heard it both
ways too
i've heard accent i've heard you know
explosives and
obviously it must have been some form of
explosives but whether it was a bomb
intentionally set off it ended up being
a bomb
but no i've heard it both ways it could
have been an accident and it could have
also been something that was very
offensive and
i wouldn't be very happy with
to follow up on that mr president even
if you just have suspicion that the
beirut explosion
is a bomb do you have any plans of
pertaining to you as assets in the
region for example i mean how are you
looking into this
we're working very closely with the
government and we're working very
closely with many different agencies
including the military
and we'll be able to figure it out we
already probably have figured it out
thank you very much everybody
abruptly walking off of course after
floating multiple
multiple unfounded conspiracy theories
now just a bonus clip here
not a conspiracy per se but just the
wild claim
donald trump again talks about you know
coronavirus is just going to go away
sir uh you said an interview this
morning on the corona virus this thing's
going away
it will go away like things go away
despite ongoing cases
isn't that true um it's going away no
it'll go away like things go away
absolutely it's no question in my mind
it will go away please go ahead
hopefully sooner rather than later now
what's pernicious about this is that to
the non-thinking individual
eventually trump's going to be right and
he's going to get some credit for that
and what i mean by that is
i guess it's conceivable that the the
coronavirus goes away as a pandemic but
it becomes sort of seasonal like the flu
but in a certain sense eventually trump
will be right that the pandemic is going
to end now trump has been saying this
for months
when we had 15 cases the president said
they would soon be zero we're now at 5
million
he's been saying it's going to go away
for five months at a certain point he
will be right
and there are people in our country so
uneducated or so blinded
by partisanship that they're going to
praise trump for it they will say look
trump said it was going to go away
and it went away it is weaponized
ignorance
and aggressive delusion and it's
dangerous and
i do you guys think these briefings are
helping trump with
some people like do these briefings help
trump with his base
or are they doing more harm than good
you'll remember they were stopped for a
period of time and then restarted as an
idea for
helping donald trump recover in the
polls he actually
has seen slightly better polling since
he has restarted these although to make
a causal relationship
uh we'd have to have a little more
information what do you think helping
hurting trump no impact helping with his
base but hurting with everybody else
curious what you think you know i told
you over the last few months that dr
anthony fauci who's the top infectious
disease doctor in the country
needs a security detail because of
threats against him
and we it's really a sort of glimpse a
peek behind the curtain into the
problems that we have as a country here
in the united states when the doctor
trying to stop the pandemic and save
people
has so many americans wanting to hurt
him
furious with him believing that he is
trying to hurt americans
targeting him as some kind of nefarious
player
in some bizarre amalgam of conspiracy
theories involving
uh bill gates and microchipping and rfid
and all sorts of stuff
he needs security that's utterly
unconscionable think about how crazy it
is that
in most countries a pandemic comes
everybody defers to the public health
officials
and to the doctors who specialize in
infectious disease
not in the u.s in the u.s the pandemic
comes
and such a large portion of the country
is
furious with the doctors that the
doctors end up needing security to
protect them
from americans let that sink in
well now it's even worse it's not just
dr fauci
who is at risk dr fauci admitted earlier
this week that now
his daughters need security to protect
them because of the work that dr
fauci is doing dr fauci said he and his
family have required
continued security in the face of
harassment
and death threats because people are mad
at what he is doing
in terms of the coronavirus pandemic
trump said we have 15 cases which will
be zero soon in march
people are mad at dr fauci and
threatening his family a quote from a
recent interview he did with cnn
commenting on this dr fauci says the
unseemingly things that crises bring out
in the world i don't know if unseemingly
i don't know if that makes sense but i'm
quoting dr fauci the unseemingly things
that crises bring out in the world
it brings out the best of people and the
worst of people and getting death
threats to my family
and harassing my daughters to the point
where i have to get security
it's amazing i wouldn't have imagined in
my wildest
dreams that people who object to things
that are pure
public health principles are so set
against it
and don't like what you say and i say
namely in the world of science
that they actually threaten you i mean
that to me
is just strange now what's really funny
here
is that dr fauci during this interview
refers to there being a degree of
anti-science sentiment in the united
states
that is quite the understatement half
the country according to multiple polls
doesn't even plan
to get the coronavirus vaccine if and
when it is available to them
but this is this is a bigger issue this
anti-intellectualism that underlies all
of this has been growing for a long time
if you go back and read some of my
favorite authors like the work of carl
sagan from decades ago if you look at
what isaac
asimov wrote decades ago they saw it
coming they've been sounding the alarm
about not sort of benign
anti-intellectualism and anti-science
and rejection of science in the united
states
they have been sounding the alarm about
the real world impact that it
was having and could potentially have
significantly more of
they were completely correct and for all
of these folks who talk about as
i mentioned yesterday trump derangement
syndrome which is just a term to stymie
debate
um we if anything have been not
alarmist enough about this issue
of rejection of science
anti-intellectualism and also
pseudo-intellectualism which presents
its own set of risks that i've
previously discussed
instead of revering our doctors and our
scientists
they've become enemies for i mean would
you say it's for
20 30 40 percent of the country imagine
threatening someone
for trying to help the american people
imagine
threatening the children of someone
trying to help
the american people and almost every day
americans find
new novel ways to make the united states
a laughing stock and a global
embarrassment and this is
in a sense as i mentioned you know when
i mentioned carl sagan and isaac asimov
this was predicted this is what happens
after on the one hand
decades of underfunding schools and
not prioritizing understanding science
and critical thinking and epistemology
and you combine that with the political
party the republican party that benefits
from that raises
money on the basis of rejecting science
uh and also religiously based
reactionary ideas although that's not at
the core of what we're seeing now with
the virus necessarily
there are more components i'm being
overly simplistic
but those are two big important pieces
of the analysis
imagine what it's like for dr fauci day
to day
going to work trying to deal with a
hundred year pandemic
seeing other countries successfully do
it
and knowing that not only are we failing
because of the president
but that the president is a huge part of
why
a large portion of the country hates dr
fauci some to the point that they would
like to see him dead
redoubling my sentiments from an earlier
segment
we owe the world an explanation and an
apology
and by the way for if trump wanted to
stop this
if donald trump spent a week saying
leave dr fauci alone i don't want to
hear
anything about anybody going after dr
fauci or threatening his family
his interest is the health of the
american people if trump did that
95 98 99 of this would stop but instead
trump is actually part of the problem
rather than the solution
imagine being a health expert in the
medical field
and having death threats hurled at you
and your family
for trying to protect the public and
having the president of the united
states
actually foment that treatment rather
than tell people
to stop and to cut it out for lack of a
better term
it's bad really really bad we have a
voicemail number which is 2192 david p
this is an interesting observation about
some of these recent interviews that
donald trump has been doing take a
listen
hey david i was just listening to the
fox and friends
interviewers your coverage of that um
i realized that trump at this point has
gotten
so bad at inter so bad at even the
propaganda interviews
yes that they literally have to give him
the answer
before he answers their question if you
replay the brian kill me he asked the
question
gives him the answer and then waits for
trump to just say yes
basically yeah that's what we're going
to do and he still
finds a way to mess it all up yes i have
noticed this
it friendly interviewers will pr it's
sort of like
priming a five-year-old to give you the
answer that that you know how like
when you talk to little kids just by how
you talk to them you can basically get
them to go along with with a lot of
different things and you say
hey uh little donnie um
do you like it is the apple or the
cherry bigger right which one looks
bigger does that apple look bigger
yes yes the apple looks bigger you're
priming answers
and friendly interviewers will do this
to trump and they'll do it when they ask
them these
seemingly simple questions like what is
your agenda
or something about the virus they give
him the answers
and trump could say you're absolutely
right that's exactly right and i'm glad
that we're all on the same page
trump still gets the answers wrong when
some somebody gives them the answers
and uh a astute uh
that's an astute observation from our
caller on the bonus show today
los angeles is saying they will shut off
water and electricity
to homes hosting large parties and
gatherings in the context of coronavirus
can they do it what will happen we will
discuss
also new york city as we are starting to
see a resurgence in cases in a lot of
different states
new york city is setting up quarantine
checkpoints for travelers who are coming
in
from coronavirus hot spots massachusetts
is thinking about similar
strategies what is the fall going to
look like and lastly
on top of everything we've gotten an
updated 2020 hurricane forecast
and it looks very bad and we already saw
in florida what happens when you combine
a relatively small hurricane tropical
storm
with a coronavirus outbreak we are going
to discuss what happens
when it is a major hurricane combined
with the coronavirus hot spot all of
those stories and more on today's bonus
show
i'll see you then or tomorrow
thanks so much for watching today's full
episode of the show just a reminder
today's
sponsor is blinkist the app that lets
you read or listen
to an entire non-fiction book in just 15
minutes you can try blinkist for free
and save 25 percent off of a
subscription
when you go to blinkist.com david pakman
i've also included the link right
underneath this video